hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to will you press the
button now the first question that we
got lined up is actually rather
insulting I just came here to have a
good time and I feel so attacked right
now you actually have to do something
productive but you have to get off this
website I never do anything productive
with my life ever ever ever ever never
now fine fine I'll do something
productive but it kind of defeats the
purpose because I press the button and
now I have to get off the website how am
I going to do anything productive if I
press the button I'm still on the
website however whatever magic exists
and you are the most powerful of the
mages but you have to vow to never harm
or kill a living creature even incidents
for self-defense that's fine I didn't
plan on killing anyone or anything as it
stands in my own life why would one I
suddenly get super powers of magic I
would call it a rampaging killing spree
I think that's okay I am a force for
good it's great you press the button
but the button doesn't work what the
hell what these catch-22 I don't
understand sir conundrum it's a paradox
you can't do this I won't be a part of
this
oh god button nothing okay you become a
tyrant of a country and turn it into a
superpower but your country will go down
the path of Hitler's Germany so
basically you'll be Hitler there's no
way around this there's no but there's
no catch it's just press this button and
you become Hitler well I don't think I
want to be labeled as Hitler today I
think I'll just move on with my life
being markiplier for at least a little
bit please start your life with all the
knowledge you currently have but you
can't recreate the relationships you
currently have
all that's different so you know all
this stuff but like what would happen
with your family
oh man you couldn't meet anyone that you
know oh god I mean it'd basically be
like starting your life over again
I guess you'd grow up in a different
area but still be the same person that
would be so weird man I wouldn't know
Bob I wouldn't know wait I wouldn't know
Tyler and Jesse and all my friends back
home I wouldn't have any other
relationships our dad man but I'd know
things like I would know everything that
happened in the world and I imagine that
the butterfly effect wouldn't be too
terrible that it changed things on a
huge scale I guess man that oh man I
don't oh that's a 50/50 split right
there what would you guys have done I
can you can have anything you want but
you're trapped in a dome for eternity
eternity is a long time let's just say a
long time we're talking to end of the
universe eternity but if I have anything
that I want how big is this dome is it
the size of my body is it a perfectly
shaped dome to my by masu mning it's
like a dome the size of a city maybe and
that dome is for some reason drifting
through the universe and you can't
control where it goes would you live
long enough to do I guess if you have
anything you want you to get anything
you can make you live longer this is a
weird question I don't know but I get
anything I want
am I gonna be alone in this dome is
there gonna be nobody with me in the
dome that's a big part of this do I have
access to it outside of the dome is that
one of the things that I could have
anything I like yes yeah if I'm alone in
this dome though but anything I want I
could bring people in I could have
friends in my dome they would be stuck
with me and then eventually hate me
let's press the button let's have a
party with a bunch of people that hate
me every party have been to birthday
parties with no that's I'm just kidding
I never had a birthday party and that's
true you have unlimited money to buy
anything except food but you must fight
to the death for your food for every
meal holy crap breakfast lunch and
dinner
and Who am I fighting please tell me I'm
fighting adorable little bunny and then
do I have to eat what I fight oh god do
I have to eat what I kill is that worth
nothing unlimited money what if I'm
killing Greg do I have to eat Greg oh
god I'm putting a lot of thought into
this I probably shouldn't I don't know
yeah whatever I'll press a button I'm in
a button-pressing mood you can have
three wishes of your choice but with
each wish one person who knows who you
know dies and I'm assuming it's at
random and I'm assuming the rules would
be you can't wish for them back to life
without defeat the point cuz then you
just make the wish they've died and if
you wish goes that would be a circle and
just stupidity you would put someone
through suffering but they didn't need
to go through one of these wishes gonna
do could I wish for world peace could I
sacrifice for the greater good like who
I don't do I know that many people
what about would all the fans that I've
met over the years count in the pool of
people that I know I mean technically
I've met a lot of people out there and
that sounds bad for me that I'm trying
to soften the blow of this by increasing
the number of people that I know and
that's not what I'm trying to do I sound
like a really meanie puss I blew up
Detroit for a piece of cake this is
still bad but not as bad as that I think
that if these wishes are genie wishes
that are unlimited but restricted by
rules I think for the greater good for
the greater good I'm figured about the
greater good I'm not doing this for
selfish intentions I'm totally doing
this for selfish in touch but if it's
for the greater good yes you're all
pressed upon Oh God I threw my fans
under the bus for power oh you will
become famous for many things including
music TV shows etc but every second you
are on camera your hair stands up in
every place and looks like
oh that's hilarious
I would actually like that if at every
moment the in that oh my god then I know
when there's a camera on me because if
I'm in my bedroom and everything is like
sticking out like this and all of a
sudden it goes back to suave and nice
there's someone spying on me I would be
the secret NSA weapon or anti NSA weapon
I would know when people are trying to
spy on me
that's beautiful of course of course
I'll press the button who wouldn't
perfect half of Earth will become a
beautiful utopian paradise but the other
half will become a barren dystopian
hellhole okay so does that force half of
the population to go to the dystopian
hellhole or can they move to the
beautiful utopian paradise is there some
magical barrier that's keeping them from
interacting with each other because that
doesn't seem good and I mean who's to
say who goes where I mean what a
beautiful utopian paradise sounds pretty
good to me but three bit three point and
a half billion people's - what if it's
like men in the dystopian hellhole and
women in the utopian paradise what if
that's how its split up well change the
dynamic of everything really quickly
they would only have to live there for
one generation cool or or research
cloning very quickly for stem cell
research let's assume that's what it is
and we we men just revert back to mad
max-style grunting and killing of each
other in the dystopian hell yeah let's
do that let's do it why not you will
instantly learn everything that you have
to in school but the internet will
explode why not just study hit the
frickin books why'd you risk the
Internet no don't be lazy don't press
that button we need the Internet I need
the internet I need to see boobs it
literally says you'll instantly learn
everything that you have to in school
not everything you'll literally own and
depending on what school you're in like
if you're in junior
Highschool and the only half to learn up
to algebra 2 that doesn't bode well for
everything in your future and you blew
up the internet for that you lazy lazy
sack of crap
god damn it sure let's blow it up fine
you have perfect eyebrows but you have
an uncontrollable desire to punch a baby
I already have that uncontrollable
desire deep down within me it's hard to
restrain the baby punching beast that
lives inside yeah I'll take perfect
eyebrows my eyebrows are a nightmare I
don't know are they good I've never
really considered how my eyebrows are
every woman man will love you but all
the people is obese
that's not funny but the way it's
written is really funky all the people
is obese well I'm assuming that
considering the way you structured that
sentence that the people is like a band
or something and all the people is a
band and they are obese so I'm going to
use my deductive reasoning to say that
that's not all people are obese that
means all the people is obese so I'll
press it you become the best inventor
scientist and engineer in the world
inventing a lot of things to make life
easier in various uses but you'll be
seen as a villain and as you use your
voice oh if I could be an engineer I'll
press it yeah sure oh man this kind of
relates to would you rather than I did
you will be a Jedi in the Star Wars
Universal but you will be followed by an
on killable Jar Jar Binks well see see
the thing is the Jedi in the Star Wars
universe don't have a very good survival
rate even if they do get to use the
Force they tend to die a lot there
aren't many old Jedi besides Yoda and he
still died all sorry spoilers everybody
so you know mmm
hi it doesn't hi this is the I will not
I've had a good Street compressing
buttons here but I'm not going to do
that you become the sexiest person alive
but your IQ drops 20 points now this is
a funny question not because of what's
in front of me but because I know that
in the comments immediately after this
question would show up it's gonna be
nonstop people well if I'd lost 20
points I'd still be a genius
like everyone in the comments in the
next page has 180 IQ and nobody can
prove otherwise so let's see that's fine
I'll still be above average I'd rather
be smart an IQ score of 110 to 120 isn't
too bad cuz 140 is genius level so my
eye is 140 okay I'm still riley smart my
IQ is already blue 20 oh man yep my IQ
is 149 so it'd still be above average
thank you very much yeah everyone in the
comments is a member of Mensa my
downside everyone thinks that their IQ
is a hundred and forty no oh god it's
like this comment section proves that
they don't they just don't oh my god oh
my god I'll leave this one with you you
will find the person of your dreams but
they are really into eating small
animals so take that for what you will
decide what small animals that they're
eating or like decide the size of animal
that they eat underneath that because
I'm pretty sure that's a blanket sweets
to sweep statement but anything under a
Yorkshire Terrier and under it's a small
animal and they will eat it they would
love to eat it so anyway thank you
everybody so much for watching let me
know what you'd pick in the comments
down below
and as always I will see you